in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Robert
and Julie are with us hey guys how are
you good Dave are you doing great
welcome welcome where you guys from
Milwaukee Wisconsin that's a bit of a
haul to Nashville well welcome to the
south we're glad to have you and you're
here to do your debt-free scream you man
up I love it
now how much have you paid off sixty
three thousand five hundred and forty
dollars and 98 cents I love it and how
long did that take you 13 months making
what kind of money right at a hundred up
to 140 okay what do you guys do for a
living I am a hospice social worker and
actually work at a Bible Camp do
maintenance guy fixing stuff okay
perfect excellent very good so what kind
of debt was the sixty four thousand
we're absolutely average dave was a
little bit of everything
medical bills credit cards IRS debt
student loans no car loan oh yeah we had
a car loan - yeah absolutely
okay yeah your normal you had everything
it's like a normal American as all the
money comes in all the money goes out
and can't figure out where it went cuz
it's all in payments yep yep Wow Robert
sent along the way it was seventeen
reminders every month in bills of how
much of a disaster our life was it's
almost everyday in the mailbox yeah
there's something there to remind you
yeah I hate it so did you sell anything
to get out of debt yeah we sold some
stuff not as much as we probably like to
we just kind of had a cash flow we sold
a couple of vehicles so snowmobiles
bunch of stuff we don't really need
mm-hmm
but we pretty much cash loaded okay so
under ten thousand dollars worth of
stuff I tended twelve okay all right
around there all right the rest of it
you cash flow yeah you did this fast I
mean you guys have been on beans and
rice then it was a hustle Dave yep
everyday big-time big-time so what
happened thirteen months ago tell me
about your journey what caused this well
we we've gone through the class couple
years ago at our awkward church in
Hartland Wisconsin
and it never really kicked in completely
I wasn't ready I was trying to run a
remodeling company and never gotten
control the income and and all that
stuff I ended up closing that business
got it asked me to close it a while ago
and I waited and waited and kept pushing
ended up letting go of that business got
a new job we actually met these two
people sitting over here at our church
and they helped us get focused they had
been through it they were proven they
were proving to us that it could be done
mmm so once we had a regular income we
started budgeting I said in disgust it's
gonna take us three years I didn't have
taken us 13 months Wow and watching them
live debt-free and what that looked like
and the potential that we had based on a
debt-free life was the motivating factor
so there was the intersection of some
people in your life modeling it yeah and
the stabilization of your income and
that's at the 13 month mark yep and
believe this or not they ended up back
in Switzerland in Europe and then now
they live here at the time of our debt
free scream so we came down to do it and
now they live here so they're back in
our life for this no perfect
that's excellent as it should be I love
it
way to go you got it so when you people
here you paid off sixty four thousand
dollars in just over a year and you make
like a hundred to some change I mean
it's not that's a lot and they say those
words how did you do that what do you
tell them that the keys are the secret
is to getting out of debt
well I always say it's a lot of hustle
you hustle Robert likes to say it's we
said no 63,000 times and the other thing
we were just talking about today Dave is
the fact that there's always somebody
wanting your dollar and you gotta want
your dollar and have a purpose for your
dollar more than somebody else does oh
that's good that's really good and we
ended up I don't know where I just lost
my thought trying not to cry I guess but
it was just it was such a heart change
that had to take place in me Julie was a
saver already so we did it by Robert
changing it's kind of what happened I
had to stop being concerned about the
next vehicle or the next toy or trying
to run a business and look good on the
outside
and I was killing us on the inside and
now you're free yeah that's that's
that's that's a very big deal yeah
that's a very big deal you know I think
that's the most important thing that
happens in Financial Peace University or
in somebody's life when they go through
this is that the exterior does change
the the $64,000 is gone but in order for
that to happen the interior change the
inside change the heart change is
amazing because this is about behavior
and behavior doesn't change until your
heart changes so that's a powerful
statement Robert that's very powerful
it's very insightful good stuff what was
the hardest ugliest thing you had to go
through we were prepared for that
question Dave and I think that the
hardest part of this whole process was
being able to give up what the culture
says is the right thing and it's not the
right thing it's what's best for us and
so the extra shifts that I picked up the
extra jobs that Robert did were the
barbecues that we missed
were the get-togethers that everyone
quote unquote does those were the hard
things because everyone wants to put
that pressure on you and it's okay it's
okay for this duration of time it's okay
because it's the right thing for us it's
the right thing for us to do yeah we're
gonna live like no one else other later
we can live and give like no one else
and Dave I wanted to make sure people
hear this we also were able to tithe and
give about ten thousand dollars last
year during this process so if you take
our income - no taxes - our lifestyle
you know that's about it and God's more
powerful than math and I believe in that
so I just want to make sure that message
got out that we didn't have to stop
tithing and we didn't have to stop
giving we actually did better this year
than we've done in the years past
because we're organized
got a plan yeah and you were executing
this is what first this is what second
is it is step by step by step but and
and it's getting around and getting on
top of this and you telling it what to
do is today at managing you yeah and
that's a big big deal well
congratulations you guys I'm very proud
of you Thanks neat couple very fun how's
it feel now that you're going
famous ah amazing yeah that's awesome we
were actually I'm fighting this morning
which is great we rented a place out
here we've been out here since Friday
and we were fighting about what's the
next step you know we know what we want
to do we'd like to pay cash for a house
but we know the time constraints on that
we'd like to get that done in a couple
years but just you know it's hilarious
because we're here we are sitting here
you know everything's great we don't
have any payments but it's like it's
still life we still have to live our
life and follow the plan and do what's
best for us in all the time
perfect yeah good for you guys way to go
all right Robert and Julie Milwaukee
Wisconsin $64,000 paid off in 13 months
making a hundred up to 140 counted down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
well done you two very well done and I
love it
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim